Transcriber: Mohammed Shami
Gözden geçirme: Aslı Narcı
Herkese merhaba.
Ben konuşmama bir soru
ile başlamak istiyorum.
Muhtemelen ergenlik yaşlarınızdan itibaren
hayatınız boyunca duymaya
mahkum kaldığınız bir soru bu.
Kendinizi tanıyor musunuz?
17 yaşında, artık üniversiteye
hazırlanan, meslek seçimi yapacak,
hayat gidişatını çizmeye
çalışan biri olarak,
sürekli maruz kaldığım
bir soru bu aslında.
Kendinizi tanıyor musunuz?
Genellikle insanların evet
kendimi tanıyorum
diye cevap verdiğini duyabilir gibiyim.
Fakat aslında sizler,
kendinizi tanıdığınızı sanacak
kadar kendinizi tanımıyorsunuz.
Belki en sevdiğiniz rengi, en sevdiğiniz
yemeği, yapmaktan hoşlandığınız şeyleri
size burada sorsam cevabını
hızlıca verebilirsiniz.
Fakat yaşınız kaç olursa olsun
ileri ki süreçte gerçekten kim olmak
istediğinizi biliyor musunuz?
Dördüncü sınıftan itibaren önce
hayat bilgisi diye başlayıp
sonra da sosyoloji, psikoloji,
hatta devamını siz getirin birçok
ders var bu alanlarda
bu şekilde dallanıp budaklanan
sosyal bilimler derslerinde
kişiliklerimizin yani beğenilerimizin
davranışlarımızın
yani genel olarak daha
hayata karşı tutumunuzun
ailemiz toplumumuz çevremiz nedeniyle
etkilendiğini ve şekillendiğini
biliyoruz belki
ama bize hiçbir zaman
gerçekten kim olduğumuz
ve neden öyle
olduğumuz sorgulatılmadı.
Yaşadıklarımızın neden yaşadığımızı,
ve insanların ilişkilerimizde
bize karşı tutumlarını,
onların neden öyle
davrandıklarını irdelemeyi,
neden sorusuna aslında biraz da
içimize dönerek kendimize sormayı
öğretmediler bizlere hiç.
Yaşadığımız her olumsuzlukta
ya karşımızdakini suçlamayı
ya da onlara kırılmayı seçtik
çünkü böyle öğrenmiştik.
ama sonra büyüdük ki ben hala büyüyorum,
ve bir şeylerin de farkına
varmaya başladık.
Yani umarım bu şeylerin farkına
varmaya başlamışızdır.
Yaşadığımız her anda tüm
yaşantımızda aslında,
bizleri etkileyen her şeye karar veren de
hayatımızın gidişatını
belirleyen de sadece bizleriz.
Bu konuda çok fazla klişe laf duyacaksınız
ki duymuşsunuzdur da muhtemelen.
Birçok aslında Ted Talks da
dinleyebilirsiniz bu konuda.
Ama benim asla unutamayacağım
bir şey varsa oda annemin
ki kendisi en büyük rol
modellerimden biridir.
Bana algılandığın kadarsın deyişidir.
Gerçekten de öyleyiz.
Bakın bir düşünün.
Yanlış anlaşılmalar hiçbir zaman
sadece tek tarafın nedeniyle
oluşacak durumlar değildir.
İletişim kopuklukları da
sadece tek tarafın kapalılığıyla
oluşacak durumlar değildir.
Burada önemli olan,
her yaşantımızda aslında o anı yaşayan
o anda farklı kişileri de etkileyen
ve de etkilenen kişilerin o taraflardan
birinde olduğumuzu unutmamaktır.
Olumsuz alanlarda bulunan da olumsuzluklar
içinde büyüyen bir insanın
kalbindeki o boşluk gittikçe
nasıl artıyorsa,
kendini iyiye adamış, huzurla
donatmış hayatını bir insanın da
iletişim kalitesinin, hayat kalitesinin,
karşısıyla kurduğu
ilişkilerinin güzelleşmesi aslında
aynı kapıya çıkmakta bakarsınız.
Sonuçta yaşadığımız her
şeyi biz etkiliyoruz.
Bir düşünün, yarın önemli
bir işiniz var ve saatlerce
ne giyeceğinizi seçiyorsunuz.
Akşam yatıyorsun,
sabah kalkıyorsunuz hazırlanıyorsunuz.
Ve çıkıyorsunuz.
Evden çıktıktan tam 12 dakika sonra
farkına varıyorsunuz ki
Artık o kombininiz ne sizi memnun ediyor,
ne de o güne uygun bir şey.
Bu kadar küçük bir şey bile gününüzü
negatif etkilerken,
hayatımıza bakışımızın, hayatımıza
kendimizi koyduğumuz konumumuzun,
hayat gidişatınızı ve yaşantınıza
yansımamasını bekleyemeyiz ki sonuçta.
Peki, hayatımızın gidişatını daha
da güzelleştirmek için,
konumumuzu iyileştireceksek
bunu nasıl yapacağız?
Maalesef ki çok satanlar listesinde iki
tane kişisel gelişim kitabı okumakla
olmayan bir süreç bu.
Bu süreçte insanın kendi konumunu
bulabilmesi için,
ve değerlendirebilmesi için
öncelikle kendini bulması gerekiyor.
Ve insanın kendini bulma süreci de,
maalesef sadece bir kere yapıp da
a tamam ben artık kendimi tanıyorum
ve  her şeyim tamam
diyebileceği bir süreç değil.
Hatta bu süreç muhtemelen köpek
balıklarından korkan birinin,
okyanus dalışı yapmaya karar vermesinden
veya yükseklikten korkan birinin ki
onlardan biri de ben oluyorum.
Skydiving yapmaya karar vermesinden daha
da cesaret gerektiren bir süreç.
Çünkü bu süreçte o zamana kadar
bildiğiniz doğrulardan,
o zamana kadar belki de
kabul ettiğiniz doğrulardan,
hayatınızın bir çoğunu geçirmiş
olduğunuz insanlardan
ve o zamana kadar da tanıdığınız
ve karşınızdakilere de tanıttığınız
ben kişisinden o yanılsamadan
vazgeçmeyi göze almanız gerekecek.
Bu süreç biraz zorlu olabilir.
Biraz korkutucu bir süreç.
Dediğimiz gibi birkaç kere yaşayacağımız
ve genellikle daha korkutucu
olacak bir süreç.
Ama bunu da unutmamak gerekiyor ki
insanların bazen daha güzeli
daha iyiyi bulabilmesi için
öncelikle bir şeyleri kaybetmeyi
göze alması gerekir.
Bu süreçte da asıl önemli olay aslında
kendinizi bulmaya çalışırken
kendiniz kaybetmekten korkmamaktır.
Çünkü kendinizi tanımaya
karar verdiğiniz o anda,
ve kendinizi tanıma sürecine girdiğinizde
o adımı ilk attığınız anda
karşınıza aslında hayatınızın
en büyük ödülü çıkacak.
O, ödül de sizin.
Ama bu sefer gerçek kişiliğinizin, aynada
gözüken altın yaldızlarla bezenmiş
bir yansıması olacak.
İşte şimdi başlıyor aslında süreç.
Bu noktadan sonra o aynayla ve o aynada
gördüğünüz yansımayla ne yapacağınıza
bağlı olarak da bir süreç ilerleyecek,
hayatınız değişecek.
Çünkü artık sizin o içinizdeki ışıltıyı
yansıtmanızla
etrafınızda dolaşacak kişiler de
aynı parlaklığa erişmiş
olan insanlar olacaktır.
Artık ilişkilerine, hayatına,
tüm bakış açısına,
o altın parlaklığı yansıtan da sizsiniz.
Hayat kalitesi gelişen, ilişkileri
gelişen de sizsiniz.
Ama burada da unutmamamız gereken bir
nokta var ki
bu süreçte değişen karşınızdakiler olmadı.
Bu süreçte değişen aslında sizsiniz.
O altın yansımayı görüp onu benimsemeye
ve hayatına yansıtmayı
seçen de sizsiniz.
Yani takdir aslında tamamen sizlerde.
Sonuçta karşınızdaki kim olursa olsun,
yani bu anneniz, çocuğunuz, sevgiliniz,
ya da en yakının bile
dediğiniz kişi olsa da
onların gerçekliklerini belirleyen
sadece sizlersiniz.
O etken sizsiniz.
Çünkü karşınızdaki insanların
gerçeklikleri, karşıya yüklediğiniz duygu
düşünce, his silsilesinin somutlaşmış
durumundan başka bir şey değil aslında.
Bu noktadan sonra karşınıza
kim ne gelirse olsun,
yani dünyanın en kötü insanı bile olsa
artık karşısında
çıkan olumsuzlukları
siz o altın parıltınızla
maskeleyeceğinizden
düşmanınız bile olsa, karşınızdaki
artık sizi yıpratamaz.
İşte asıl güç dediğimizde bu, içimize
dönüp kendimizi iyice tanıyabilmek.
Aynada gördüğümüz o altın parıltıyı
güzelce benimseyebilmek.
Son olarak, aynı yere bir
daha dönmek istiyorum
Fakat bu sefer cevabını verirken biraz
beklemenizi rica edeceğim bu sorunun
Aynaya baktığınızda artık
altınlara bözenmiş
kendi yansımanızı görebiliyor musunuz?
Kendinizi tanıyor musunuz?
Bu noktadan sonra da artık altın rengi
en sevdiğiniz renk değilse,
kişisel tanıma da artık biraz daha adım
atmanız gerekiyor.
Teşekkür ederim (Alkış)